savoir que ces 83 % des français qui
sont connectés à internet dont 87% tous
les jours donc c'est ce qu'on apprend
dans un baromètre de l'association de
l'économie et du numérique pas et la
poste et pourtant trois français sur
quatre n'ont pas confiance dans les
informations qu'ils trouvent sur les
réseaux sociaux comme nous l'indiquent
notamment donc cet internaute sur
snapshot
c'est un nouveau moyen assez rapide et
efficace mais qui fait perdre de vue que
l'actualité ne se résume pas en quelques
secondes ou quelques phrases ce moyen
facile rend les gens si paresseux de
lire de chercher et d'écouter les médias
traditionnels
alors c'est vrai qu'entre les faits que
news les buzz inutile partager des
millions de fois sur twitter piratage de
comptes fuite de données personnelles
bref les craintes sont très nombreuses
alors qu apprécie-t-il au final vraiment
sur les réseaux nous sommes une émission
interactive nous vous donnons la parole
et voici ce que vous m'avez répondu à la
question twitter 52 % considèrent que
les réseaux sociaux sont fiables et 48%
voilà celle ci pour les médias
traditionnels je vous le disais donc
c'est très contrastées alors voilà ce
qu'on m'a répondu à cette question
pourquoi sofia nous dit les réseaux
sociaux tout simplement parce qu'on y
trouve également les informations des
médias traditionnels
nous les premiers effectivement le
figaro on a encore henry qui nous dit
les médias rapportent souvent ce que le
maquereau nisme leur dicte alors que les
réseaux sociaux voient le réel
quotidiennement et le transmettent sans
masquer la vérité il ya toujours cette
crainte en fait et cette manipulation de
manipulation demande d'indépendance des
médias de la part des internautes
on a encore jane qui nous dit dans la
mesure où les médias sont très présents
sur les réseaux sociaux
l'un va avec l'autre on a aussi ana qui
nous dit les réseaux sociaux on peut
voir tous les avis de tous bords alors
que les médias selon elle ne donne que
le leur pour finir on à drieu qui
développe un peu plus il n'y a aucune
vraie pluralité dans les médias
traditionnels ils sont muselés par le
politiquement correct et ils ont tous
plus ou moins la même vie
du monde bien sûr il ya toujours des
outsiders mais qui sont évincés lorsque
leurs paroles se libèrent
voilà donc les avis les internautes sur
twitter
on terminera avec ce tweet de la poste
donc partenaire de ce baromètre que je
vous mentionnais tout à l'heure dans ce
baromètre on apprend également que 86 %
des français considèrent qu'internet
donne accès à une diversité de points de
vue cette émission je pense n'a jamais
aussi bien porté son nom
avec ce tweet des points de vue oui on
leur donne via les réseaux sociaux les
vôtres